the finale of Sabrina this season was
very crazy it was wasn't it oh we have
the to Sabrina's yeah Sabrina's to
Sabrina's but I do want to start with
your guys's characters obviously so
let's talk about what's going on with
Roz and Harvey yeah things seem to be
pretty good like they fell off strong
you know Roz and Harvey you know they
said the l word love you husband I love
you too
Harvey kinkle that did the sex thing so
you know things are going strong for
Harvey lens carbon or ha ha ha just like
wow really are it's a hard one be like
ha I do okay it sounds just as well I
know you guys had started filming the
next we are you finish last
okay so then we've been going since May
and we finished a few days ago yeah
that's yeah I hope you know what kind of
hurdles then do we see four for Harvey
for has her we got hives we committed I
mean there's it definitely stays
interesting and awesome
I mean Harvey and rahzar going strong as
of late so we'll see what part 4 brings
for sure what about a Theo and Robin who
I by far the cutest couple
oh yeah murder no doubt the most
horrible and weird which I am oh man
I think we're going strong for the
moment then I may or may not be some
drama he may or may not have some old
old flings old friends coming to town to
cause some problems but I think I am
pushing for in game and game in game man
so we're really looking to the future
with that like a burrito me hydrometer
like so
johner said we're like I'm cool with
this yeah this works yeah all right
Robin are you really gonna stay in
Greendale what would he so that Robin
does stay in Greendale because that was
the question was is he that is the
question that's definitely gonna be the
question in part four I think this is is
he arrested I just feel like Robin can't
leave Greendale
I just feel like he fits right in but
also he's a little Hobgoblin like he
lives in shooting stuff Dale we're full
of witches Greendale you know finish are
we gonna learn more about his backstory
actually some bits and bobs and I'm
really excited to tell that story and I
know I know John is too oh yeah very
very pleased you teased some old flings
or friends is there new blood coming to
Greendale there's always new blood and
there's always one green there's gonna
be lots of ABS you ever have lots of
lots of minute will happen I love the
ABS we are at Lee's lot 78 yeah yeah
lots of shirtless moments fresh meat
anything that could shake up any of the
romances always we always got to keep it
interesting
yeah some drama got to keep you on on
the edge yeah you wonder the shippers
action yeah give them something to talk
about yeah let's talk the to Sabrina's
because it seemed like for the Sabrina's
it was a solution to all the problems
but it also seems like it would create
more chaos
it sure it way I did that a viable
solution turns out a lot of things go
wrong because of this decision turns and
it's kind of a not that we are untying
for most of wait something goes wrong
because of a rash decision Sabrina maybe
yes yeah she does I'm very happy oh yeah
I know Sabrina might have a little
trouble I know both of them both of
their eyes Double Trouble envy you well
what does it mean for Sabrina's love
story arc in the next season Tori's
that's what love story is that double
the romance is there something still
there between her and Harvey that was
sort of teased for sure well with Harvey
and Sabrina I'm the way that I feel
about it like those those season 1
moments are so special and precious and
beautiful and wonderful and I love those
scenes and I just feel like with your
first love like there's always a part of
you that is gonna love them and connect
with them because you shared something
so special together so I think there's
always gonna be that that spark and that
recognition of hearts between them I
just don't see that going away how does
that affect Ross well Roz is not stupid
but she's also very compassionate I
don't I don't rust I don't really feel
like we spent any time seeing Ross be
jealous because her and Harvey are so
happy that it would be strange for her
to be jealous can we see more of her
powers more than you're gonna see more
of her get ours a lot more of her powers
yes are you excited I think I'm at home
yeah part 4 is exciting for us okay
father Blackwood in the egg situation in
between what do we think that invasion
why do you think he's just crazier and
crazier and little remain here every
time oh my gosh it's some fun stuff to
do working with my chosen sands yeah I
get to create more layers and then I
love it and I'm so excited I'll enjoy
watching my words is my favorite thing
to do it just always entertaining and
just watch him move his face whose life
is so evil
eyes are like so happy when he's doing
it like wait little psycho why are you
guys working with him y'all just have to
see but we have them working with him
later this variation but it's something
that they both wanted like yeah the
stars we've been talking about how we're
like the farthest away on the spectrum
anything for those worlds to me oh I
know they do in those worlds may or may
not collide that is very exciting so
then what do you think causes the most
danger in season 4 is it the father
Blackwood is at the to Sabrina there's
so many things part bores like this like
amalgamation that's what I was gonna
calculate it all comes together so
there's just a bunch of things going
wrong all of the things so all of it and
more okay amazing is there maybe one
thing for each of you that you're
excited for fans to get to seeing yes
and I cannot tell you what it is can you
give us a hint it's cool it's about my
power and it's very very cool yeah I'm
just elated for more throbbin content
Frank what are you robbing a terrible
it's better than like sobbing no it's
not it's so much better Johnny I decided
first week it's throbbing and no one can
tell me I'm Robin that's controversial
canon
[Music]